Es ist wieder soweit, die Ligatour Europa ist zurück und heute im XXL-Format. Wir sprechen heute mit Chris McCarthy über die Premier League, mit Daniel Zander über die Eredivisie, mit Jakob Hafke über die Liga, mit Fabian Pakulat über La Liga und mit Mario Riga über die Serie A. Ich muss das Intro abfahren. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Lyon.
Das hatte ja voll die Morning-Radio-Vibes. Es tut mir sehr leid für diese völlig exaltierte Ankündigung. Aber ihr freut euch ja auch, dass die Ligatour wieder zurück ist, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr wieder mit dabei seid und schön, dass ich hier diese große Runde habe. Einmal ein kollektives Guten Morgen, ihr Lieben.
Also, in der Liga ist wirklich übel, Platz 14 mit 27 Punkten. Und dazu muss man sagen, im Februar wird es richtig hart. 1. Februar Manchester City, 7. Februar Manchester United, 10. Februar Newcastle, 22. Februar Arsenal. Also, das haut schon ganz schön rein. Da ist es nicht zu erwarten, dass sie damit 12 Punkten rausgehen aus diesen vier Spielen. Ja, das ist ja Teil des Brustes der BVB-Fans zu Recht auch, dass man bei diesem Tottenham, bei diesen Spurs, so eine erste Hälfte gespielt hat und in der zweiten Hälfte im Unterzahl er letztlich gezeigt hat, was möglich gewesen wäre. Aber ja, es sollte nicht sein. Dann blicken wir mal weiter in La Liga. Fabian, über was ist denn da noch zu sprechen? Ich habe es vorhin schon so ein bisschen angeteased.
Ja, ich bleibe heute königlich und komme von den Königlichen aus Madrid zur Königlichen Gesellschaft aus San Sebastian im Baskenland. Die haben nämlich einen sehr überraschenden Schachzug Ende des Jahres, vergangenen Jahres gemacht, nämlich sie haben mit einem neuen Trainer verpflichtet, der keinen Stallgeruch hat. Normalerweise setzen die Basken ja sehr auf Eigengewächse in den letzten Jahren. Und sie haben mit Pellegrino Matarazzo einen Trainer geholt, den viele von uns wahrscheinlich noch kennen aus seiner Bundesliga-Zeit Hoffenheim, Stuttgart. Dann war er aber lange weg, zumindest habe ich ihn überhaupt nicht mehr auf dem Schirm gehabt und dann hat er plötzlich bei Real Sociedad San Sebastian unterschrieben. Ein Club, bei dem es stark gekrieselt hat, seit Immanuel Aguasil den Verein verlassen hat. Sie haben es dann wieder mit einem eigenen Trainer versucht, also der der zweiten Mannschaft, der so hochgezogen worden hat, nicht funktioniert. Die sind weit unten in der Liga rumgekrebst, haben aber rein kadermäßig und infrastrukturmäßig natürlich höhere Ambitionen. Und Matarazzo hat tatsächlich aus seinen ersten drei Pflichtspielen zwei Siege und einen Unentschieden geholt, ist im Pokal weitergekommen gegen Osasuna, nachdem man da schon 0-2 zurück lag, hat in Chitapec gewonnen mit 2 zu 1, hat Unentschieden gespielt gegen Atletico Madrid und hat zu Hause jetzt Barca geschlagen mit 2 zu 1. War zwar viel Dusel dabei, hatte ich vorher schon angekündigt, weil Barca hätte eigentlich auch 5-6 Tore machen müssen können. Haben sie ja teilweise auch wurden dann aber aberkannt. Aber Dusel muss man sich irgendwo auch erarbeiten. Und deswegen ist dieser Einstand, muss ich sagen, tatsächlich sehr geglückt. Sie haben sich in der Liga ordentlich jetzt nach vorne gearbeitet. Und ja, eine sehr interessante Verpflichtung, wie ich finde, völlig unerwartet und scheint aber zu funktionieren. Und finde ich eine ganz gute Geschichte für den Trainer, der ja, glaube ich, US-Amerikaner ist, aber dann doch in Deutschland irgendwie aufgewachsen ist und dadurch ausgebildet worden ist mit Nagelsmann zusammen und so weiter. Und der jetzt La Liga bereichert.
Und spielt er denn auch so einen Ballbesitzansatz, wie wir es beim VfB und bei der TSG gesehen haben?
Also es ist auf jeden Fall im Vergleich zu vorher deutlich offensiver geworden und auch intensiver, was das Pressing anbelangt. Schnelles Umschaltspiel, also ja, da hat er schon viel mitgenommen. Und die Defensive von San Sebastian war sehr anfällig vor allen Dingen. Das hat er dadurch jetzt aber stabilisieren können, weil die Mannschaft jetzt einfach mehr Druck nach vorne macht und dementsprechend natürlich auch die Defensive entlastet ist. Und das tut dem Klub ganz gut. Ich habe da auch einen 19-Jährigen, der gerade hinten in der Innenverteidigung steht, einen Talent. Das ist natürlich nicht so ganz einfach. Und wenn du natürlich den Ball eher hast bzw. eher den Weg nach vorne suchst, dann entlastet das eine Defensive. Und wie gesagt, die Ergebnisse im Moment sprechen ja tatsächlich für ihn.
Und das war, also ich glaube, alle haben, oder wer es mitbekommen hat, dass Matarazzo der Trainer ist, der hat es wahrscheinlich ähnlich mitbekommen wie ich, nämlich nach dem Sieg über Hansi Flick und dann den herumgehenden Beams in wirklich Fußball-Nerd-Kreisen, dass man dann gemeint hat, ah, okay, alles klar. Ja, schauen wir, wie es weitergeht für Real Sociedad. Jetzt dann gegen Celta Vico, Athletic Bebau und dann geht es ja ins Viertelfinale der Copa del Rey. Könnte schon sein, dass er da was aufbauen kann. Bin ich sehr gespannt darauf. Dann blicken wir nochmal in die Eredivisie, Daniel. Was hast du uns da noch mitgebracht?
Ja, ich hatte ja vor vergangenes Jahr hier im Rasenfunk schön gesagt, na ja, ich glaube, Veynord, die wäre sicher meister. Und ich glaube, das war eine der größten Fehlprognosen in den letzten Jahrtausenden. Also aktuell ist PSV auf 1 mit 16 Punkten Vorschwung vor Veynord. Und naja, gut, es hat sich noch ein bisschen gewandelt. Und ich glaube, die andere große Fehlprognose hängt bei mir im Schrank. Das ist ein Werder-Trikot mit Flock-Navigator. Das ist die andere große Fehlprognose.
Warum haben wir jemals auf dich gehört? Hätte mir das gewusst.
In dem Punkt, naja, gut. Also immer gucken, was größer ist. Aber es kommt relativ nah dran, beide Sachen.
Warte mal ganz kurz. Denkst du, Clemens Fritz ist ein guter Sportdirektor?
Ich möchte mich nicht außerteilen. Vielleicht. Ich leihe erst mal wen aus.
Okay, ich dachte, du gibst noch eine Prognose.
Nein, ich hab nichts zurück. Aber ich kann versuchen zu erklären, wie ich zu diesem Tuchschluss kam. Ich glaube, wie sehr viele auch in der Divisi. Ich hab mich ein bisschen blenden lassen von der Art und Weise, wie Robin van Persie's Taktik bei Feyenoord so gut funktioniert hat. Also, wir hatten jetzt schon den Dementorenfußball in Italien. Das ist so ein bisschen Wildwestfußball in unserem westlichen Nachbarland. Also, van Persie spielt wirklich teilweise echt sehr, sehr offensiv im Fußball, geht voll drauf, versucht echt hohes Gegenpressing und hat eigentlich so ein Grundsystem, so ein 4-3-3. Im Ballbesitz, im Angriff ist es teilweise ein 3-1-6. Also, wenn man durchzählt, findet man wirklich acht Spieler, teilweise im und um gegnerischen Sechzehner. Das ist wirklich, wirklich krass. Hat, wenn es funktioniert, die Folge, dass du natürlich ständig einen Druck hast auf den Gegner. Du hast die ganzen zweiten Bälle, die gewonnen werden. Du hast permanent echt ein aggressives Positionssystem. Die Gefahr ist, wenn es schief geht. Hast du halt hinten große Räume und dann hast du schnell Konter-Situationen. Jetzt hatten sie ein sehr wildes Spiel am Wochenende. Dann haben sie verloren auch ein 4-3 gegen Sparta, wo sie am Ende beim 3-3 auf sie gespielt haben, waren auch wieder mit 8 Mann vorne. Und dann gab es ein, zwei lange Pässe und da hatten sie eine 4-2-Situation gegen sich. Die haben sie dann auch zum Tor geführt. Diese Art von Spiel hat in den ersten Spielen herausragend funktioniert. Da hatten sie mit die wenigsten Gegentrohre trotz dieser Spielweise in der Liga. Weil da die Identität gestimmt hat, die Abstimmung gestimmt hat, und da haben viele gesagt– eilglich nicht mehr –,Dass wenn sie das durchhalten, sie gute Chancen haben, weil PSV so inkonstant war zu Beginn der Saison und Feyenoord eben nicht. Das Problem ist, dass sich das Ganze, das Überladen der Abwahrreihe und dieses aggressive Spiel, so langsam von einigen Mannschaften dekodiert wurde, so ein bisschen. Sie haben in der Anfangsphase die Gegner von Feyenoord oft versucht, sich rauszuspielen und versuchen, da so ein bisschen durchzukommen. Es hat aber nicht funktioniert. Es war ja auch so ein bisschen dieses Lockmittel von Van Klaassen, das sie mit der Gegner einladen will, es mit Kurzpass zu versuchen. Diese langen Bälle eben nicht verspielt. Die kommen jetzt vermehrt. Da zeigt dann doch dieses System auf Dauer, auf Langstrecke, so ein bisschen Schwächen. Das hat dazu geführt, dass dann Feyenoord etwas inkonstanter wurde und da hier mal ein Punkt liegen gelassen hat. Und bei Eintrufen, die haben sich im Gegenzug relativ schnell, relativ konstant stabilisiert, weil sie auch einfach ein bisschen Glück haben. Die haben ja auch einige Ausfälle. Der Player, den es auf Gladbach fehlt, ist immer noch verletzt. Das hatten sie jetzt bei dem Afrika-Cup Saibari, der jetzt nicht so viel Umstand, auch recht lange nicht, weil er im Finale mit Marco war. Da haben sie aber das Glück, dass sie just in dem Moment, wo man Saibari, ein wichtiger Kreativspieler, nicht mehr spielen konnte für Pace Way, Paul Wanner eingeschlagen ist. Der hatte einen sehr schnellen Stand zu Beginn, kam nicht zum Zug und jetzt konnte er die Chance nutzen bei Pace Way und macht jetzt seine Tore und ist ein wichtiger Faktor geworden im Mittelfeld. Da haben sie auch ein bisschen Glück. Und als letzten Grund noch– es klingt immer so, wie eine Ausrede– aber die Verletzungsbeserre bei Feenord ist auch schon echt gewaltig. Die haben Jakob Moda im Mittelfeld, fällt seit August eigentlich schon schon aus. Die haben in der Defensive den Trauner, der ausfällt. Die haben den Theorit, der bei Bayern immer mal wieder in der Gerüchteküche auftaucht. Der fällt jetzt bis März noch aus. Ueda im Sturm, der relativ wichtig ist für die Offensive, ist jetzt auch angeschlagen derzeit im Spiel gegen Sparta. Da haben sie jetzt Hans-Musa erwischt, mal gucken, wie schlimm es bei denen ist. Also es sind nur einige. Das spielt dann in der Masse auch, glaube ich, eine Rolle mit dem Traun. Und ja, jetzt ist für jetzt für eben 16 Punkte Vorsprung. Und wie sagt man so? Ich glaube, jetzt werden die Meister. Ich wechsle mal die Fahne. Ich lasse die mal aus, meine Fahne im Wind.
Oh je, das Urteil ist gesprochen. Feyenoord holt wieder auf. Aber dann wird es wenigstens spannend. Sehr schön, Daniel. Und du warst ja dessen ja auch schon bewusst, dass du am 2. Oktober eine Frühprognose abgegeben hast, dass du dich da weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt hast. Aber das darf ja auch mal sein. Und gerade die Verletzung in der Innenverteidigung, auch Thomas Beelen fehlt ja glaube ich auch schon die ganze Saison über. Und der hat in der Vorsaison schon Stamm gespielt, glaube ich. Und gerade wenn wir über so Restverteidigungsthemen sprechen, da macht es dann doch wahrscheinlich einen Unterschied, ob die individuelle Qualität die höchste ist, die du gerade im Kader hast oder halt nur ganz weit höchste.
Aber es macht auch gerade deswegen sehr viel Spaß, Fan-Nords zu schauen aktuell. Es hat zum Beispiel den Sohn von Van Persie, der spielt jetzt auch. Und der hat jetzt bei dem Vierterei hat er gleich mal einen rausgehauen, nämlich ein Hackentor und ein Fallrückzieher-Tor. Zum 2-3 und 3-3. Hat dann in der nicht gereicht, aber da sieht man auf jeden Fall schon, da ist auch Talent vorhanden.
Und das war ein schöner Fallrückzieher.
Vor allem, und der hat auch den Papa-Ni-Slide perfektioniert, bei diesem einen Jubel. Der hat mich sofort an den Papa erinnert, wie er da gerutscht ist.
Ach, ich sehe schon. Also diese Nachwuchs-Väter-Eltern-Mütter-Folge, irgendwann müssen wir sie doch noch machen. Sie drängt sich ja geradezu auf. Aber Mario, wenn du jetzt eh dein Mikro offen hast, wir haben jetzt gerade über jemanden gesprochen, der hat abreißen lassen, wollen wir dann jetzt über jemanden sprechen, den der Serie A hat abreißen lassen in der Tabelle.
Können wir gerne machen. Der Name wurde ja auch gerade schon mal getroppt. Der liegt nämlich nicht am Strand, sondern der macht sich und seine Mannschaft Mürbe. Antonio Conte. Und ich bin ja Fan davon, wenn man mit irgendwelchen Hot-Tags aufräumt, die man mal gemacht hat, wo man daneben lag. Hab ich glaube ich zwar nicht hier gemacht, aber ich habe mich irgendwo mal dazu hinreißen lassen, zu sagen, dass ich glaube, dass das vielleicht die erste Saison wird, in der Antonio Conte nicht nur Liga kann, sondern auch Champions League. Und jetzt lassen sie zum einen in der Liga abreißen, aber auch in der Champions League stehen sie knapp unterm Strich von den Playoffs, was ja in diesem Ligasystem, das da gespielt wird, finde ich schon ganz schön harte Nummer ist für den amtierenden Meister. Und ja, die Probleme bei Napoli, die fangen früh an. Also wenn man zu Hause 0-0 gegen Eintracht Frankfurt spielt, glaube ich, weiß man so ein bisschen, wo das Problem ist. Sie sind zu ungefährlich im Sturm. Sie haben zu wenig Spieler, die treffen. In der Champions League haben tatsächlich nur Rasmus Heul und Scott McTominay Tore geschossen dieses Jahr für die SSC. Und das, was Daniel gerade auch gesagt hat, ist, das muss man ihm vielleicht irgendwie so zu Gute halten. Wir haben auch unfassbar viele Verletzten. Also ging ja los mit Kevin de Bruyne, aber jetzt in den letzten Wochen fehlt ständig in einem Mannschaftsteil eine tragende Säule, ob es jetzt wieder in der Innenverteidigung Rachmani war, der da wegbricht, ob die Flügelzange erst Neresch sich verletzt, jetzt auch noch Politano, wo dann auch Antonio Conte auf einmal mit Nachwuchsspielern in der Champions League auflaufen muss, was er wirklich, ich glaube, da muss der überredet werden. Vielleicht früher hätte er zu Zehnt gespielt, bevor er noch irgendeinen Jugendspieler einwechselt, so und jetzt hat er auf einmal noch mal vier auf der Bank. Das ist schon ein bisschen besorgniserregend, vor allem, weil ich mich noch bis vor vier Wochen über so einen richtigen Dreikampf auch in der Meisterschaft gefreut hatte. Jetzt haben sie zwar auch neun Spiele nicht verloren, allerdings innerhalb der letzten fünf Partien waren vier Remis mit dabei, unter anderem auch gegen Abstiegskandidaten wie Hellas, Verona und Palma, 0-0 gegen Palma, die davor auch wirklich in jedem Spiel immer gegen Tore gefressen haben und eine wirklich unstabile Abwehr haben. Das ist echt ein wenig ernüchternd, vor allem wenn man sich so ein bisschen drauf gefreut hat, dass sich da hinter Milan und Napoli battlen. Und in der Champions League, wie gesagt, da sind acht Punkte gleichauf mit Kopenhagen gegen, die sie jetzt da gespielt haben. Und am letzten Spieltag hat man ein Heimspiel gegen Chelsea, die jetzt nach dem, ich glaube auch nicht so wirklich überzeugenden, aber Sieg gegen Parvus immer noch die Möglichkeit hätten, unter die Top 8 zu kommen. Ich glaube, das ist auch nicht irgendwie, dass die nach Süditalien fahren und sagen, da lassen wir ein bisschen auslaufen. Und gerade wenn man sich das anguckt, wie intensiv diese Art Fußball spielen zu lassen von Konte ist, glaube ich, sowohl körperlich als auch mental. Vielleicht tut es ihnen sogar gut, gar nicht weiterzukommen in der Champions League, aber das kann halt nicht ihr Anspruch sein. Auch monetär gesehen, was sich da ist, wieder in diesen Kader gesteckt haben. Und da ist er dann auch wieder derjenige gewesen. Erst waren es ihm zu wenig Neuzugänge, dann waren es ihm zu viele, weil wir sollen sie alle integrieren. Jetzt sind es natürlich wieder zu wenige, weil er ist dann, also das ist auch wieder Antonio Konte, Masterclass auf jeder Pressekonferenz. Das ist höchst unterhaltsam, wenn man halt irgendwie nicht ganz so mit dem Herzen an dem Verein dranhängt. Und ich glaube aber für die Tifosi da schon sehr, sehr schwer. Und sie haben halt auch ein paar richtige Ruhrkrepierer geholt. Ich glaube, Chris Lorenzo Luca soll ja irgendwie in die Premier League verschifft werden. Ich weiß nicht, ob da der Verein, der ihn dann holt, Spaß dran hat. Der läuft rum wie Falschgeld. Das wäre eigentlich noch mal so einer, den sie da vorne irgendwie als Stürmer gehabt hätten, der ihnen dann mal was wegnipst. Aber bei dem funktioniert überhaupt gar nichts. Und ja, weil PSV gerade Thema war, ich habe die sind auch einmal komplett drübergerollt über Napoli. Freue ich mich aber sehr drauf, Daniel, melde ich mich nächste Woche mal bei dir. Da darf ich nämlich nach Eindhoven. Da werde ich noch die eine oder andere Frage zu Peter Boss Fußball. Genau, also das ist bei Napoli gerade so der Stand der Dinge. Es kommt jetzt immerhin Lukaku zurück. Der saß jetzt auch schon wieder ein paar Mal auf der Bank. Der bekommt wohl dann demnächst die eine oder andere Spielminute mehr. Der war ja auch in der Meistersaison so mit der Schlüsselspieler für Antonio Konter, auch wenn Scott McTominay alles überragt hat.
Also schauen wir mal. Ich meine, es sind nur sechs Punkte auf Inter, drei auf Milan. Die wird man auch noch spielen, irgendwann im Frühjahr dann. Aber ja, der Trend ist wirklich schlecht. Ich habe das Kopenhagenspiel nur in der Konferenz gesehen. Aber da hat man sich jetzt nicht eine Tutechips-Vorbegeisterung aufgemacht.
Na, vor allem, sie spielen in Überzahl, gehen in Führung und spielen dann noch irgendwie über eine Halbzeit eben gegen Zehn und kriegen trotzdem kaum Torschancen kreiert und fangen sich dann so ein dummes Elfmeter gegen Tor. Hätten sich danach schon von der Standardsituation fast den Ausgleich gefressen. Das spricht, glaube ich, dafür auch, wenn ich sage, so diese mentalen Anforderungen, die Antonio Conte an seinem Team hat. Die Mannschaft wirkt sehr müde und ja irgendwie befangen.
Da liegt so ein bisschen Mehlstaub drauf, Mehltau heißt es, glaube ich. Na ja, also Napoli lässt abreißen. Dann blicken wir nochmal nach Frankreich. Jakob, du hast uns ein wunderschönes, also du hast es hier überschrieben mit das nächste Kapitel in der wunderbaren Welt des Multiclub-Ownership. Da habe ich ja schon wieder so richtig Bock drauf. Was ist jetzt schon wieder los?
Ja, wie kann man denn eine Rasenfunk-Folge Ligatour international machen, ohne mindestens einmal über Multiclub-Ownership zu sprechen? Und welch schöneres Beispiel könnte man sich da aussuchen, als über Racing-Club Strasbourg zu sprechen? Die– es ist ja so ein bisschen verknüpft mit einem der Themen, über das Chris auch vorhin schon gesprochen hat, denn es geht ja um den Trainerwechsel bei Strasbourg. Zu Saisonbeginn war es ja noch der Kapitän, der dann mitten während der Saison mit einem Chelsea-Trikot posiert hat und sich so gefreut hat auf seinen anstehenden Sommerwechsel nach den harten Verhandlungen zwischen den beiden Vereinen. Und dann war es jetzt in der Winterpause, oder Winterpause in Anführungsstrichen, der Trainer von Strasbourg, der dann ja plötzlich auf der einen PK noch gar nichts davon wusste, dass er überraschenderweise Nachfolgekandidat von Enzo Maresca sein sollte und dann ein paar Tage später aber logischerweise doch weg war. Also Liam Mourinho ist nicht mehr Trainer bei Strasbourg. Er ist zu Chelsea gewechselt und ja, ich glaube, das Echo bei den Fans und den Supportergruppen von Strasbourg kann sich jeder von uns vorstellen. Und ich glaube auch jeder von uns kann das Gefühl nachvollziehen, wie man sich fühlt, wenn der Trainer einfach so mitten während der Saison geht und einem einfach ja klar und deutlich vor Augen geführt wird. Dieser Verein ist eine B-Mannschaft und hier wird– ich meine, es ist ja– warum ist man Fußballfan? Man ist Fußballfan, weil man– auch wenn jeder weiß, dass es inzwischen sehr, sehr klein ist, dass man die Hoffnung hat, dass ja zumindest theoretisch maximaler Erfolg möglich wäre und dieser Illusion wird man halt komplett beraubt, wenn man merkt, okay, es gibt einfach innerhalb des eigenen Vereins Personen, denen ist der Erfolg der eigenen Mannschaft nicht wichtig oder sogar egal oder er ist sogar kontraproduktiv. Weil es gibt dann ja immer noch die Frage, was würde eigentlich passieren, wenn die beiden in der Champions League sich qualifizieren würden? Dann könnte ja– soweit ich die Regularien der UEFA verstanden habe– wenn man nicht es schafft, eins der Schlupflöcher zu nehmen, würde sich dann ja das Team qualifizieren, was in der Tabelle höher steht. Nehmen wir an, Straßburg wäre dritter, Chelsea vierter. Dann wäre das für die Vereinsbesitzer echt beschissen.
Das wird nicht passieren, dass dann Chelsea nicht steht. Die müssen ihre Anteile am Verein in einen Treuhandfonds geben für die Zeit, in der der Wettbewerb läuft. Und das muss man aber bis zum 1. März angemeldet oder vorbereitet haben. Das war ja das Problem zwischen mit Lyon und Crystal Palace.
Aber trotzdem ist es halt so, okay, wir die Straßburg-Fans haben jetzt nochmal vor Augen geführt bekommen, dass es einfach nicht im Interesse ihrer Besitzer ist, dass sie jetzt den maximal größten Erfolg haben. Zumindest solange man denkt, okay, der Chelsea braucht irgendwas aus diesem Verein, dann wird Chelsea das auch bekommen. Und ich glaube, dieser Konsequenz ist wirklich sehr, sehr bitter. Es gibt vor jedem Spiel eine 15-Minuten-Protestphase, wo es keinen Support gibt von den Fans, jetzt auch seit Monaten schon. Aber ich weiß nicht so wirklich, ob da ein Ende in Sicht ist. Chris wollte zwischendurch was sagen.
Genau, als du die Proteste angemerkt hast. Ich muss dazu sagen, das ist natürlich ein anderes Level, wenn du der B-Club dieses Konsortiums bist. Das ist ja nochmal viel frustrierender, viel schlimmer für die Fans zu ertragen und alle Beteiligten. Aber es ist nur ganz interessant zu erwähnen, dass auch bei Chelsea aktuell oder zuletzt es Proteste gab, eben wegen diesem Modell von Bluko, also der Gruppe quasi, weil das ist ja auch nicht im Interesse der Fans, dass eine Mannschaft so eine Mannschaft da ist, um Investitionen voranzubreiben und Gewinne zu erzielen, sondern man will Titel gewinnen. Und das sorgt auch bei Chelsea Fans für Frust, natürlich auf einem anderen Level. Aber ich wollte nur sagen, dieses Konstrukt, was da geschaffen wurde, sorgt auch bei den Nutzniezern davon, bei der nutzniezenden Mannschaft, ebenfalls für Frust.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass es halt schon auch ein Problem ist, wenn der sportliche Erfolg dann nicht so richtig sich einstellt. Zumindest, ich sage mal so, wäre Chelsea jetzt weiter in einem Meisterschaftskampf, wäre der Unmut gerade von Seiten Chelsea sicherlich geringer. Aber auch bei Straßburg würde es zumindest etwas mehr die Probleme kaschieren können, nicht unbedingt so dauerhaft, aber zumindest kurzfristig hat das ja beispielsweise in der letzten Saison schon ganz gut funktioniert, weil man da ja das erste Mal seit längerem wieder wirklich auch oben mitspielen konnte. Und jetzt in dieser Saison, man spielt ja auch keine Katastrophenrunde, aber man steht halt auch in der Liga nur auf Platz 7, hat den Kontakt an die Champions League-Ränge ein bisschen verloren. Und was dann noch dazu kommt, die Leihspieler, die man von Chelsea hat, funktionieren eigentlich nicht gut. Also Kendri Páez spielt fast gar nicht. Der Keeper Mike Pendas macht es ganz gut, aber jetzt auch nicht viel besser oder eigentlich sogar ein bisschen schlechter als Petrovic, den man letzte Saison von Chelsea ausgeliehen hatte im Tor. Also hat man sozusagen da auch noch mal ein Downgrade bekommen. Mamadou Sarr in der Innenverteidigung, ja, den hatte man vorher eh schon. Deswegen ist auch da so der Faktor, okay, das ist jetzt ein Spieler, den wir vielleicht sonst nicht gekriegt hätten, nicht so gut, auch wenn der ganz okaye Leistungen zeigt. Aber es funktioniert halt nix. Emmanuel Mega, der Kapitän und eigentlich ja auch Star und Leistungsträger des Teams, spielt gar nicht, ist fast die ganze Saison verletzt, wechselt dann im Sommer zu Chelsea, wo, glaube ich, alle eigentlich ganz froh drüber sind, weil er sich auch abseits des Platzes nicht so sonderlich beliebt gemacht hat. Er hat nämlich auch in einem Interview zum Beispiel erzählt, dass, bevor er nach Straßburg gewechselt sei, die meisten Fans oder die meisten, die sich nicht so mit dem französischen Fußball beschäftigen, gedacht hätten, dass Straßburg eine Stadt in Deutschland gewesen wäre. Also, glaube ich, auch eine Äußerung, die sicherlich bei der Lokalbemerkung…
Als nächstes gesagt, dass Elsas könnten wir doch auch wieder abgeben. Das ist ja Wahnsinn. Ja, okay.
Also da bemüht sich jemand auf jeden Fall, alle Brücken einzureißen auf dem Weg nach London. Ja, und dementsprechend ist die Stimmung in Straßburg nicht gut, obwohl man zum Beispiel in der Conference League auch immerhin auf dem ersten Platz die Tabelle abgeschlossen hat. Also da auch vielleicht sogar noch ein Titel holen könnte. Auch im Pokal jetzt durch das Aus von PSG ist ja einiges möglich. Aber ja, die Fans sind ziemlich desillusioniert.
Verständlich. Und das Schlimme ist bei diesem Multi-Club-Ownership, wir müssen das Thema nicht wieder zum 1000. Mal aufmachen, aber der sportliche Erfolg, also Titel, das ist für die Eigentümer dieser Vereine eher so das Zubrot. Also nur wenn du es quasi aus Sportswashing-Gründen her machst, dann willst du halt auch mal die Champions League gewinnen, weil das quasi der hellste Stern ist, der strahlen kann im Fußball. Wenn du es aber machst, um Geld zu verdienen aus dem laufenden Betrieb, dann musst du einfach nur in der ersten Liga bleiben. Klar, möglichst gut, aber es geht über das TV-Geld und es geht über das Premier League-TV-Geld, alles andere ist völlig egal. Und das macht es ja nochmal so mehr frustrierend, dass man sich denkt, ja gut, für die Blue-Co macht jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so den riesen Unterschied, ob Chelsea jetzt 8. oder 7. oder 6. oder 5. oder 4. wird. Nur wenn sie wirklich den Titel haben wollen würden, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann würde es einen riesen Unterschied machen. Das heißt, das Grundprinzip des Sports wird auch ein bisschen ausgehebelt. Naja, so, jetzt habe ich gute Laune. Wollen wir dann nochmal in die Premier League gucken?
Kann ich der Vollständigkeit halber noch kurz erwähnen, wer jetzt neuer Trainer ist bei Straßburg. Das habe ich nämlich jetzt ganz vergessen. Da hat dann nämlich auch die Wahl des neuen Trainers jetzt nicht gerade für Enthusiasmus gesorgt, denn es ist mit Gary O'Neill, ein Trainer aus England, gekommen, der jetzt auch bei Wolverhampton Wanderers und– wo war er noch? bei Bournemouth jetzt nicht so unbedingt für riesige Begeisterung gesorgt hat. Und ich glaube auch, das ist jetzt kein neuer Trainer, der einen träumen lässt in Straßburg, ohne dass ich jetzt sagen würde, das ist die schlimmste Wahl, die man hätte treffen können. Aber man hat mit ihm jetzt auch immerhin in seinem ersten Spiel den ersten Ligasieg seit dem 9. November geholt. Also mal schauen. Vielleicht kann er ja die Erwartungen so ein bisschen widerlegen und dann doch für ganz gute Stimmung sorgen, zumindest auf dem Platz.
Also ich kann nur zumindest für alle, die es gerade nicht im Video gesehen haben, der Gesichtsausdruck von Chris, das war eher so, dass das Emoji mit den hängenden Mundwinkeln, würde ich jetzt sagen, bei der Erwähnung von Gary O'Neill. Aber gut, Chris, was hast du uns denn aus England noch mitgebracht?
Ja, noch einen kurzen Blick zu Per Mertesacker, der nach sieben Jahren als Nachwuchsleiter Schluss gemacht hat, beziehungsweise zum Saisonende geht. Und ich dachte, es lohnt sich gleich mal drauf zu blicken, wie man ihn bei Arsenal in Erinnerung behalten wird für seine Arbeit. Auf dem Platz und neben dem Platz. Er war jetzt 15 Jahre bei Arsenal, das vergisst man schnell. Ziemlich lange Zeit. Und man hält auch sehr, sehr große Stücke auf ihn bei Arsenal. Und gerade in der Nachwuchsabteilung, was er dort geleistet hat, ist vielleicht, wenn wir jetzt gerade von diesen unschönen Aspekten des Fußballs oder des Geschäfts sprechen, war Mertesacker großer Initiator in einer gewissen Philosophie. Die Strong Young Gunners hieß das und oder heißt das. Da war er der Initiator. Und das diente dazu, den jungen Leuten, Spielern, Menschen, soll man da in der Stelle vielleicht auch betonen, wichtige Werte zu vermitteln wie Respekt, Disziplin, Bodenständigkeit. Hat auch viel für Mental Health gemacht, weil eben das Geschäft schwierig ist, gerade für junge Spieler oder heranreifende Spieler. Und er hat das immer sehr in den Vordergrund gestellt. Auch hat er oft betont, dass gerade die Fälle ihm sehr nah gehen, wenn er einfach Spielern oder Jugendlichen sagen muss, das reicht wahrscheinlich nicht. Und da war er immer so eine ganz wichtige Person bei Arsenal. Und dazu muss man auch sagen, natürlich unfassbar talentierte Spieler durch die Reihen gekommen. Bukai Osaka natürlich als Erstes zu nennen. Van Eyri, der jetzt noch Marcel verliehen würde, hat auch unfassbar viel Potenzial. Dann kommt auch schon die nächste Reihe mit Max Daumann und Marley Salmon. Wir werden wahrscheinlich in den nächsten Jahren mehr davon hören. Also viel, viel verletzt talent. Und dazu muss man auch sagen, all diese Spieler auch sehr, sehr bodenständig. Also gerade weil ich das mit dieser Philosophie genannt habe, dass man merkt auch, dass das wirkt. Denn so ein Bukai Osaka, da hast du ja keine Skandale als Beispiel. Also es sind alles sehr ruhige, bodenständige Typen, sehr sympathische Typen. Und das fruchtet. Ja, gleichzeitig ist wahrscheinlich auch Arsenal bereit für etwas Neues. Nicht, weil man nicht zufrieden war, im Gegenteil. Aber man merkt auch, dass Mertesackers Fokus auf die erste Mannschaft war. Einfach Talent in die erste Mannschaft zu führen. Und eben natürlich diese wichtigen Aspekte, die ich gerade nannte. Gleichzeitig musst du als Verein oder Top-Verein in England, die Academy auch ein Stück weit als Einnahmequelle sehen, so unschön das ist. Oder das legen viele so aus, wenn du siehst, was Chelsea oder City mit Talenten an Geld verdient, die es nicht bei City schafften. Aber gut genug für andere Vereine sind. Da hängt Arsenal ein gutes Stück hinterher. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass man das jetzt auch als Chance sieht, einfach die Academy dahingehend zu nutzen, dass man hier auch ein bisschen Einnahmen generiert in Zeiten der finanziellen Zwänge, die man auch in der Premier League hat.
Come to Werder, Per.
Ja, weiß man denn, was er machen will?
Ja, gab es jetzt schon ein paar Gerüchte. Es hieß, er möchte erst mal eine kleine Auszeit nehmen oder eine kurze Auszeit nehmen.
Also bis zum Saisonende. Achso, nee, er arbeitet dann noch so lange.
Also es wurde auch schon von einem Jahr geredet, mal sehen. Es waren jetzt nur Gerüchte. Es gab auch Gerüchte an einem Posten beim DFB, kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen bei ihm. Ja, aber er scheint auf jeden Fall etwas Neues machen zu wollen und da können wir gespannt sein. Wer weiß.
Ich bin auch herhörig geworden bei der Aussage, wo du gesagt hast, wenn er Spielern gut vermittelt, dass das wahrscheinlich nicht reicht. Ich weiß, ich kann das auch bei Spielern aus der ersten Mannschaft machen.
Bezieht sich noch auf das Come-to-Werder, habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck. Aber das wäre schon richtig cool, irgendwie Thomas Bräuch, Nachwuchsleistungszentrumsleiter beim BVB per Mertesacker bei Werder. Also irgendwann können wir uns dann nur noch mit den Nachwuchsspielern beschäftigen. Ja, vielleicht will er in seiner Auszeit ein Tribüngespräch machen. Kann mir jemand Kontakt herstellen? Meldet euch bei mir. Mal gucken. Also, per Mertesacker, weg bei Arsenal am Ende dieser Saison. 15 Jahre, ey, das ist schon wirklich krass. Hätte mich raten lassen, da merkt man, wie alt man ist, ehrlicherweise.
Zusammen mit Atetta auf dem Platz gestanden, ne? Auch witzig, ja.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Stimmt. Richtig. Ja, unglaublich. Also, das ist die Premier League gewesen für diese Woche. Fabian, was hast du denn noch mitgebracht aus La Liga?
Ich habe dir was mitgebracht, was dich jetzt kurz ärgern wird, aber dann habe ich eine tolle Feel-Good-Geschichte dazu. Also, es geht leider wieder um Multiclub-Ownership, um dieses Thema. Es geht um den FC Girona aus Spanien. Der gehört ja zur City Group und da spielen auch die ein oder andere Spieler von Manchester City. Und die haben jetzt Marc-André ter Stegen verpflichtet, bis zu so einer Ausgabe. Und da kommt jetzt gleich meine Feel-Good-Geschichte dazu. Denn ihr kennt alle noch Juan Arango, Bundesliga-Legende, Borussia Mönchengladbach. Und mit wem hat er zusammengespielt bei Gladbach? Marc-André ter Stegen. Und mit wem spielt Marc-André ter Stegen jetzt in Chirona zusammen? Juan Arango. Aber es ist der Sohn von Juan Arango, der übrigens genauso aussieht.
Also es ist wirklich... Hat er auch so eine linke Klebe wie sein Vater.
So viel spielt er noch nicht. Also ich habe ihn noch nicht spielen sehen. Ich habe das auch erst vor kurzem erfahren. Es ist ein junges Talent, er ist noch relativ jung und hat noch nicht so viel Spielzeit, aber er sieht wirklich fast genauso aus. Es ist wirklich geil. Die beiden, wenn man sich so das Foto anschaut, Ters Degen mit Arango Alt und Ters Degen mit Arango Jung, das passt auf jeden Fall. Und das hat mich sehr gefreut, diese Geschichte. Und auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich jetzt die Frage, Ters Degen, Chirona, wird das reichen, um auf den WM-Zug aufzuspringen oder nicht? Chirona hat einen schlechten Saisonstart gehabt, ist jetzt so im Mittelfeld, ist gerade, ja fängt sich gerade, hat natürlich schon Qualität im Kader, weil finanzielle Mittel da sind wegen diesem ganzen Ownership-Geschichten. Auf der anderen Seite ist es so, er wird dort mit Sicherheit Stammspieler sein, denn der aktuelle Torhüter hat zu oft gepatzt in den letzten Monaten, Jahren, würde ich fast sagen, obwohl man große Stücke auf ihn hält. Muss ich noch mal seinen Namen kurz nachgucken. Ich kann ihm nie merken, Gassaniga heißt der. Naja, und deswegen wird er dort spielen. Und er wird spielen bei einem Mittelklasse-Club, was heißt, er kriegt auch ordentlich Bälle vor die Nase gedroschen. Und auch das ist eigentlich wieder eine gute Geschichte, denn klar, wenn du bei Barca oder Real oder wie auch immer im Tor stehst, da kommen halt 2, 3 Schüsse vielleicht. Und da kriegt er halt jetzt 20, 30 Dinger auf das Tor und da kann er sich jetzt auszeichnen. Chirona hat gerade einen guten Lauf. Wie gesagt, die waren weit unten, kommen jetzt gerade nach oben. Wenn er denen jetzt hilft, mit guten Paraden vielleicht sich noch vorne wieder reinzuspielen, who knows? Für ihn ist es auf jeden Fall so, dass er dort, glaube ich, jetzt einen Stammplatz hat. Der Trainer wollte ihn auch unbedingt haben. Er kann in Barcelona weiterhin leben bleiben. Er muss da nur eine Stunde rüberfahren nach Chirona. Und we will see, ob das dann auch für ihn gut läuft. Aber schon allein, dass er wieder in Arango in seinen Reihen hat, glaube ich, wird ihn beflügeln.
Schon lustig, dass der Vater Arango den jungen Marc-Andre Ter Stegen unter seine Fittiche genommen hat. Das sage ich jetzt einfach, auch wenn ich jetzt nicht weiß, wie viel er mit dem Torhüter wirklich zu tun hatte im Training. Außer dass er ihm die Bälle um die Ohren gepfiffen hat und jetzt ist es umgedreht. Aber das ist ja sowieso. Also Marc-Andre Ter Stegen, also wer dem jetzt nicht jeden Erfolg der Welt gönnt, da hat, glaube ich, die letzten Jahre nicht so wirklich aufgepasst.
Der hat den Fußball nie gelebt.
Also das ist wirklich viel gut. Danke Fabian, das habe ich jetzt noch mal gebraucht. Ist die Frage, ob Daniel da jetzt mithalten kann mit so viel Feel-Good?
Ja, so ein bisschen, ich kann es versuchen. Ich habe beim Blick auf die Tabelle in Keller gesehen, dass ein Verein namens Telstar so langsam wieder ein bisschen in Fahrt kommt. Das sind Aufsteiger, die sind in der Nähe von Amsterdam. Wir sind in einem Ort, Felsensee, die sind westlich von Amsterdam gelegen, in der Nähe vom Meer. Und da sind aufgestiegen, haben am vierten Spieltag vielleicht mal wegen Eindhoven gewonnen und danach lange nicht mehr. Aber jetzt kommen wir so ein bisschen in Fahrt. Da haben wir es gegen die Almere gewonnen, gegen den Konkurrenten unten. Und jetzt haben wir jetzt den Punkt geholt gegen Excelsior. Das heißt, da kann man so ein bisschen hoffen. Und ich hoffe auch, wer aller Neutralität zum Trotz, würde es mich sehr freuen, wenn die die Klasse halten. Ich war auch vergangenes Jahr persönlich da. Und das ist für alle Crown-Topper und Crown-Topperinnen eine dringende Empfehlung, da mal hinzugehen. Also das ist ein richtiges kleines Schmuckkästchen. Es sind drei oder viertausend fast nur da rein in das Stadion. Und es ist einfach wirklich so eine richtige Crown-Topper-Amosphäre. Also das Stadion ist quasi so äquivalent zu so einem soliden Dritteliger-Stadion hier in Deutschland, würde ich sagen. Aber einfach flutliche Atmosphäre, sehr, sehr arbeiterstillastig. Man kommt dann mit so einem Bus, wo man da hinfahren, weil da infrastrukturell nicht so viele Erbindungen sind. Aber man kann zum Beispiel mit dem Bus hinfahren, recht schnell. Man ist dann in so einem schönen Nieselregen, dann in diesem wirklichen Stadion, mit viel Baulichenlehrraum zwischen drinnen. Und die haben zum Beispiel auch super Geschichte. Die wurden in den 60ern gegründet. Und der Name TellStar kommt von diesem ersten Ferran-Satelliten, der damals in die Umlaufbahn da gegeben wurde. Das fanden die einfach toll. Deswegen dachten die sich, wir nennen uns TellStar.
Ich war froh, dass sie sich nicht im Jahr der Toaster-Erfindung gegründet haben.
Und der hat den Namen TellStar. Und der hat auch sehr, sehr– das sind die weißen Löwen in der Beinahme. Und sie ist reich Tradition. Also Louis-Françal war da auch Spieler, glaube ich der bekannteste überhaupt. Aktuell im Tor spielt der Sohn von Ronald Koeman mit dem schönen Namen Ronald Koeman im Juniore. Also auch wieder bei den Söhnen und Töchtern in der Profis. Und die reich Tradition ist ein Kultclub, sage ich mal, aber nicht irgendwie ironisch abwertend gemeint, sondern wirklich ernsthaft. Und wenn man mal in der Nähe von Amsterdam ist, kann man gut mal, wenn es in die Planung passt, ein Bus nehmen und über Haarlem dahin fahren. Es lohnt sich schon. Stimmung ist top und Reichtradition, viel Geschichte.
Das war ein schönes Thema, ich sage es ganz ehrlich. Vielleicht zweitbekanntes der Name nach Louis Van Raal, der bei Telstar begonnen hat, ist Jimmy Floyd Hasselbank. Der kommt auch dort her. Und ansonsten noch nur ein kleiner Fun-Fact, Jeffrey Snyder, also der Bruder von Wesley. Der hat dort auch seine Karriere begonnen. Sehr schön. Telstar benannt nach einem Satelliten. Warum auch nicht. Dann können wir doch nochmal, Jakob, wenn du willst, in die Liga 1 rüberblicken. Was gibt es denn da noch zu erzählen?
Ich glaube, beim Namen von Paris FC ist relativ klar, wonach das benannt ist. Und es ist ja tatsächlich das erste Mal seit Ewigkeiten, dass es auch aus der französischen Hauptstadt zwei Teams gibt, die in der ersten Liga spielen, seitdem Paris FC letzten Sommer aufgestiegen ist. Allerdings so viel Hoffnung auf so eine riesige Feel-Good-Story ist da ja nicht, denn man muss sagen, Paris FC ist weder der typische Aufsteiger noch– ja, beschreibt es so eine schöne Underdog-Story, denn Paris FC hat in diesem Sommer das größte Transferminus von allen Teams in Frankreich gehabt, hat also knapp 60 Millionen ausgegeben für neue Spieler. Es haben nur PSG und Strasbourg überhaupt, ansonsten Transferminus gemacht in Frankreich. Dadurch, dass man nicht so viele Fernseh-Einnahmen hat, sind die Vereine ja sehr abhängig von Transfer erlösen. Man hat im Hintergrund ja mit der Arnaud-Familie, das wurde hier ja auch schon mal angesprochen, hatte David auch schon mal darüber gesprochen, auch sehr, sehr reiche Eigentümer, dann ja noch eine Minderheitsbeteiligung von Red Bull, was also auch ein bisschen zum Multi-Club-Ownership-Thema treibt. Aber bei Paris FC läuft es jetzt gar nicht so gut. Ich glaube, viele hatten auch aufgrund der Finanzstärke erwartet, dass man vielleicht sich direkt in der oberen Tabellenhefte etablieren könnte. Auf jeden Fall hatten die meisten eher das Gefühl, dass man vielleicht jetzt nicht so wirklich was mit dem Abstieg zu tun haben müsste. Und das sieht jetzt bisher eher anders aus. Also man ist jetzt nicht in akuter Abstiegsgefahr, hat jetzt auch am letzten Wochenende einen sehr wichtigen 2 zu 1-Sieg gegen Nantes eingefahren, sonst wäre man ganz tief unten drin gewesen. Jetzt hat man momentan fünf Punkte Vorsprung auf eben dieses Nantes, die auf Relegationsrang 16 stehen. Aber für das, was Paris FC im Sommer ausgegeben hat, ist das Ganze, glaube ich, sehr, sehr enttäuschend. Ich habe das ja auch häufiger schon gesagt, dass viele von den Teams, die unten drin sind, eigentlich gar kein Geld haben, um Ablösesummen zu bezahlen. Also wenn dann mal so ein, zwei Millionen für einen Spieler pro Transferphase– und bei Paris FC sah das jetzt ganz anders aus von den Transfers, die sie geholt haben –,Haben auch viele jetzt noch nicht so gut funktioniert. Also zum Beispiel hat man ja für 17 Millionen den Innenverteidiger Otavio von Porto geholt. Der spielt bisher eine sehr enttäuschende Saison, gefällt mir bisher wirklich überhaupt nicht gut. Dann hat man Moses Simon geholt von Nantes, also einem direkten Konkurrenten. Hätte ich mir relativ viel von erwartet, weil der eigentlich immer so der Schlüsselspieler bei Nantes war, funktioniert jetzt auch bei Paris FC noch nicht so richtig gut. Und allgemein ja die Transferbilanz jetzt nicht so richtig super. Man hat jetzt im Winter auch schon zweimal nachgelegt. Noch hat Luca Corleoscho ausgeliehen von Burnley, der jetzt auch gegen Normt direkt den entscheidenden Siegtreffer gemacht hat und hat Marshal Munizzi ausgeliehen aus Wolverhampton. Mal schauen, wie die jetzt beide einschlagen. Auf jeden Fall Munizzi wird im zentralen Mittelfeld eine Lücke schließen, die schon so vorhanden ist. Dadurch, dass da auch mit Pierre-Lés Melou, ein Spieler, den man von Stad Brest, also auch einem Liga-Konkurrenten, die ja auch letzte Saison sogar noch Champions League gespielt haben. Aber da konnte auch Stad Brest nicht finanziell mithalten bei dem Angebot, was Paris FC gemacht hat. Der fällt jetzt schon seit längerem aus. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Spieler, der Paris FC auch sehr fehlt. Man hatte zu Saisonbeginn vor allem das Gefühl, dass die Defensive das Problem ist. Man hat schon relativ viele Gegentore gefangen. Aber jetzt auch die Offensive läuft nicht so richtig rund, obwohl da auch Spieler sind, wo man eigentlich das Gefühl hat, okay, da müsste mehr gehen. Also Jonathan Ikone war ja auch mal vor ein paar Jahren ein ganz großer Name, als er bei Lille eine überragende Saison gespielt hat und dann ja auch in Italien war eine Zeit lang. Da weiß ich nicht so genau, wie er performt hat. Dann hat man auch Willem Gjöbelz noch, ein, ja, der früher auch mal als sehr, sehr großes Talent galt, unter anderem auch bei Monaco, der in der Schweiz jetzt getroffen hatte, jetzt in der Ligue 1 auch, ja, nicht so richtig performt bisher. Aber es sind auf jeden Fall ein paar bekannte Namen dabei. Und eigentlich müsste man mit der Mannschaft, glaube ich, auch deutlich besser spielen. Es gibt jetzt noch nicht so richtig Gerüchte darum, ob Stefan Geli, der Trainer, der auch seit 2023 schon im Amt ist, wirklich unter Druck steht. Ich glaube auch nicht unbedingt, dass das der Fall sein wird. Er hat ja jetzt auch in den letzten Wochen so ein bisschen den Eindruck erweckt, als würde er den Kurs korrigieren können. Ich meine, der Pokalerfolg gegen PSG, über den wir schon kurz gesprochen hatten, war natürlich ein Riesenerfolg und auch eine echte Sensation natürlich, dass PSG jetzt mal den Pokal nicht gewinnen wird. Er hat auch, um die Defensive zu stabilisieren, Kevin Trapp inzwischen die Pfosten gestellt, der ja zu Saisonbeginn, glaube ich, für viele überraschend, also erstmal, dass er überhaupt dahin gewechselt ist, kam ja schon überraschend, dass er dann aber noch nicht mal gespielt hat, war dann doch durchaus merkwürdig erstmal mit Oberton Cambadio, hat Paris FC auch einen sehr talentierten Keeper, der aber noch nicht so wirklich reif wirkte für die Liga, hat fünf Tore mehr kassiert als es nach Expected Goals wahrscheinlich wäre in seinen Einsätzen und hat jetzt seinen Stammplatz verloren. Kevin Trapp macht das bisher auch ganz solide, auch wenn, glaube ich, jeder weiß, wo auch er seine Schwächen durchaus hat, aber ich glaube, er hilft der Mannschaft jetzt mit seiner Erfahrung schon auch auf jeden Fall. Also ich glaube nicht, dass man bei Paris FC jetzt wirklich im Abstiegskampf reden muss, aber gerade angesichts des Ungleichgewichts zwischen dem Anspruch, den sie sicherlich haben, dem, was sie signalisiert haben mit ihren hohen Transfer-Ausgaben und der dann tatsächlichen sportlichen Performance ist das nicht so ganz stark. Und da passt auch zu, dass der eigentlich beste Spieler bisher in dieser Saison, Ilan Keball, einer ist, der schon ein bisschen länger da ist, also noch vor dieser riesigen Einkaufsphase unter der Ano-Familie dann gekommen war. Der hat jetzt, glaube ich, schon 11 Scorer gesammelt, war auch beim Afrika Cup dabei und ist jetzt aber auch wieder zurück. Also, auf den kann man auf jeden Fall mal ein Auge haben. Der hat auch einen sehr schönen und sehr, sehr starken linken Fuß, schießt echt nette Tore teilweise und ist ein Spieler, den man auf jeden Fall gerne zugucken mag.
Also ja, Paris FC, also man hat das mitbekommen mit dem PSG. Es waren ja zwei PSG-Spiele nacheinander. In einem stand Trapp im Tor, bei dem, was sie gewonnen haben, dann nicht, aber das war, was eben Pokal war. Jeweils 30 Prozent Ballbesitz in einem Spiel hatten sie 6 zu 23 Schüsse. Das haben sie 1 zu 2 verloren. Im anderen hatten sie 4 zu 20 Schüsse. Das haben sie 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Also das ordnet auch diese Sensation so ein bisschen ein. Das läuft gerade noch nicht so. Aber es ist ja vielleicht auch ein ganz schönes Signal, dass man nicht alles mit Geld sich kaufen kann. Zumindest kurzfristig. Lasst mir diesen glauben.
Ja gut, den Nicht-Abstieg wird man sich zumindest kaufen können. Also so ein bisschen Hoffenheim-Wolfsburg mäßig wird vielleicht auch jetzt in dieser Transferphase nochmal Geld drauf gekippt und dann steigt man zumindest nicht ab.
Okay, cool. Dann blicken wir nochmal ein letztes Mal nach Italien. Und gut, fröhlich wird es jetzt auch nicht, Mario.
Ja, schwierig jetzt irgendwie eine Feel-Good-Story daraus zu machen, dass ein Mensch von uns gegangen ist, Rocco B. Comisso, der Präsident der Fiorentina, ist im Alter von 76 Jahren gestorben. Aber dennoch so ein bisschen, weil wir es jetzt gerade auch immer von Multi-Club-Ownership hatten etc., so ein bisschen der Gegenentwurf und vielleicht auch die eine oder andere Geschichte einer schillernder Persönlichkeit, die ihn in guter Erinnerung behalten lässt. Und ich finde schon auch in Italien ist immer, da sind natürlich auch, und er gehört da auch dazu, superreiche Geschäftsmänner, Präsidenten von Vereinen. Dennoch habe ich ganz oft das Gefühl, dass es was anderes ist. Also ist es auch in Napoli mit einem wilden Charakter, der aber stets auch so ein wenig Fan des Vereins ist, was Rocco B. Comisso auch war. Ein Junge damals, der mit 12 aus Kalabrien in die USA ausgewandert ist, das sehr, sehr viel Geld gemacht hat, dort aber auch schon viel davon in Fußball investiert hat. Unter anderem war er Mitbesitzer von New York Cosmos und hat da so ein bisschen die Mitweite entwickelt. Da kam letztes Jahr eine Geschichte raus, weil es da auch Streits gab zwischen der MLS und den eher sozusagen Amateur-Ligen, wo er dann– das muss 2017 gewesen sein– und letztes Jahr, als es eine Gerichtsverhandlung dazu gab, hat er zugegeben, dass er Fake-Twitter-Accounts genutzt hat. Damals gab es Twitter-Accounts, die einen der Geschäftsführer der MLS aufs Übelste beleidigt haben und dann hat sich rausgestellt, das war Rocco Bicomiso himself, der dort ganz derbe Worte gewählt hatte. 2019 hat die höchstmarode Fiorentina übernommen und da wirklich, also in den letzten Jahren, oft im Conference League-Finale, spannende Trainer, die da groß geworden sind, hat ein großes Leistungszentrum bauen lassen, das altehrwürdige Stadion Atemio Franky, das jetzt umgebaut wurde. Das hat er auch noch mit angeschoben. Und da habe ich auch so eine kleine persönliche Geschichte. In diesem Stadion war ich einmal und war auf der Haupttribüne und in diese Tribüne eingelassen ist die Präsidentenloge, die so ein wenig daherkommt, wie ja so ein Balkon im Theater, wo er in der Mitte sitzt. Das sieht so ein bisschen aus, als würdest du eigentlich gar nicht reinpassen, so von den baulichen Maßnahmen. Und da sitzt er, droht er auf Höhe der Mittellinie. Aber alle Menschen, die vorbeigekommen sind, Frauen, Kinder, Omas, Opas, ich auch, als ich da hochgeguckt habe, hat er auch gerade runtergeguckt zu mir und meinem Sohnemann, wie wir da hochgekommen sind, guckt dann runter, grüßt, hat sich auch in der Halbzeit mit Leuten unterhalten. Also einer, der das sehr gelebt hat, was glaube ich auch gerade an dem Standort Italien sehr wichtig ist für die Anerkennung rund um den Verein. Also die haben ihn da wirklich sehr geschätzt. Und ja, die letzten Wochen, Monate war er auch seltener da, was dann so ein bisschen komisch wahrgenommen wurde. Auch der Fiorentiner ging es ja gar nicht gut. Langtabellenletzter gewesen. Da hat sich jetzt halt rausgestellt, dass er krank war und auch deswegen nicht dort war. Und ja, anlässlich seines Todes Tages hat dann die Fiorentiner auch endlich mal ihr erstes Auswärtsspiel gewonnen und ist jetzt nicht mehr auf den Abstiegsplätzen. Also vielleicht spielt diese Mannschaft so ein bisschen die Saison für ihn auch mit zu Ende. Und weil ich es ganz schön fand und gerade jetzt irgendwie in Diskussionen um Multi-Club-Ownership auch reinpasste, habe ich einen Ausschnitt aus dem Nachruf aus der SZ mitgebracht von dem geschätzten Kollegen Felix Haselsteiner, der geschrieben hat, bemerkenswert ehrlich war Komiso stets. Manchmal auch derb. Die Angelis, Besitzerfamilie von Juventus Turin, nannte er mal Motherfuckers in seinem typisch Italo-Englisch. Wie eine Figur aus einem Film von Scorsese oder Coppola klang er dann. Wie ein Mann aus einer alten Welt, der sich von seinem Instinkt und seinem Menschenverständnis leiten ließ. Wie ein Gegenentwurf zu den Investoren und Zahlen-Jongleuren, die den Fußball als Geschäft sehen, nicht als Liebesaffäre.
Mario, das ist so witzig. Ich wollte genau diesen Absatz hätte ich jetzt vorgegeben, wenn du es nicht gemacht hättest. Das ist einfach fantastisch. Aber die Fiorentiner und Todesfälle, das ist ja wirklich Wahnsinn, was sich da summiert hat. Also ohne das jetzt irgendwie einen komischen Kontext rücken zu wollen. Aber ja, da ist noch jemand der alten Garde gegangen.
Und nicht nur Astori, den du gerade angesprochen hast, den Kapitän, der vor vielen Jahren gestorben ist. Auch so diese Geschichte noch mit Bove, mit dem Herzstillstand auf dem Feld, der leider in Italien aufgrund der Gesetzgebung nicht spielen darf. Aber ich nach England geht, meine ich jetzt.
Wattford ist glaube ich fix.
Oh Gott, Wattford, da habe ich jetzt auch schon wieder diesen Begriff auf den Lippen, den wir hatten. Aber wir machen es zu jetzt.
Ja, machen wir es einfach zu hier. Ihr Lieben, das hat große Freude gemacht. Die erste Ligatour Europa dieses Jahres 2026 und auch in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer wird es jetzt dann weitergehen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Also abonniert einfach diesen Feed oder diesen Kanal und dann werdet ihr das nicht verpassen. Ab jetzt kommen wir wieder in unsere Rotation rein. Ich danke euch fünf sehr, sehr herzlich Chris McAfee, Daniel Zehnder, Jakob Haffke, Fabian Pakulat und Mario Rieker. Ich werde natürlich verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann. Ja, und vielen, vielen Dank für eure Zeit und eure Vorbereitung in eure Themen. Danke euch. Ja, da wird genickt. Ihr müsst einfach glauben, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da wurde genickt. Dann danke ich doch auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ihr wisst ja, alles hier im Rasenfunk ist werbepayable und sponsorenfrei. Und warum? Weil ihr uns finanziell unterstützt. Auf rasenfunk.de und natürlich auch in der Podcast- und Videobeschreibung erfahrt ihr, wie man uns Geld zukommen lassen kann. Geht auf allen erdenklichen Wegen. Und dann könnt ihr euch ja einfach überlegen, welchen Gegenwert, welchen monetären Wert hat denn so eine Sendung wie diese hier für euch. Und auch an dieser Stelle noch mal der Hinweis, zum 1.1. haben wir, wie ab jetzt dann immer, unsere Gästehonorare um 3% erhöht. Das heißt, wenn ihr wollt, dann könnt ihr das doch auch gerne zum Anlass nehmen, vielleicht auch eure Unterstützung, um diesen Prozentsatz oder, wenn ihr wollt, auch mehr zu erhöhen erhöhen. Deswegen vielen herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei JWS, bei Kickers, Emden, Maniac und bei Wolfgang. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge, dann ist mitmachen.rasenfunk.de der perfekte Ort dafür. Und dann hören wir uns ja bald schon wieder, denn wenn ihr auch nur einen anderen Feed vom Rasenfunk abonniert habt, dann wisst ihr, wir hauen gerade Sendungen raus wie warme Semmeln. In diesem Sinne, bleibt oder werdet gesund und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank!